welcome to this video playing funky d
German a German player and it another
teammate of mine let's see what we get
here i'm going to play play the dutch do
something do something else for a change
okay yeah this is one of those modern
lines where why do you get the uture
space advantage on the on the queenside
yeah I think this is a very very decent
choice for white i played this stuff
myself with white going going forward
this is funny set up with Bishop Pucci
aid I know that it is probably not super
great but um yeah I have to play I have
to play something and I don't want the
same kind of opening all the time
against my teammates that day that
didn't know very well okay it's white
going to play you for successfully
probably am a gunite d7 before takes
takes rook takes at the end maybe I can
play Knight b6 at the end that's not
that clear maybe yeah that looks very
logical
it's funny how to rock chicks I could
even play Bishop c4 but this of course
weakens the light squares tremendously
yeah I'm not sure if this is a good idea
oh come on let's let's do this let's say
it's probably questionable but why not
it's not like I'm playing for the world
title and the splits games oh ha here we
go here we go hmm nice yeah yeah I was
suspecting that it should get it why
should get something Queen coming to g6
hmm okay and this is hanging
hmm
if I take here in Quincy 69 f 6 95 and
yeah that's probably just lost you
Bishop f7 95 96 yeah that this this is
also of course great for white but I
don't really see what what else I can do
yeah look aged 4 was probably strong
yeah I really don't have anything else
when h7 is also hanging so the question
is is it's not a seven the right move on
or maybe something else g5 md5 also
looks looks quite strong
yah yah yah it's not nice i know i don't
know there are probably many good news
taking on f7 and Queen g6 was probably
also just good
taking here ok
yeah it's probably still bad for me but
I don't know it feels like I should have
been wiped out already and somehow i'm
i'm still execs existing here I don't
know maybe you can push Bishop f6 Bishop
f6 maybe it's not not completely clear
Roxy a true k 2 o ok to look at you
might be an idea I don't know I need to
be a bit quicker ok Queen B 6 attending
queen bee fire just a very cheap trick I
mean maybe I get in maybe I get in rook
c6 getting them getting the exchange
back yeah i don't know i don't have much
time on the clock twin takes be five is
a very very cheap trick ok and i can
just take c6 now maybe he can take f6
and take h 7
maybe better okay I was very much
probably just lost
yeah it happens if you play this this
very double-edged openings and the other
side is really knowing what they what
they're doing can be in big trouble okay
but still it's bishop f6 or something ah
interesting ok at least I don't have any
big choice taking be to look you know c7
I just go into the CFR and look see
something plain 95 ok and I'm going back
to pieces up it's not like just one
piece
nice from deep it's situated because I
mean I was completely busted a fault
check check
I take that as rookie to weapon ok
quindi one was probably probably a
pretty good idea check check white
resign yeah okay I mean you can we can
now check how how I could have been how
I could have been busted him I'm really
not sure about efore but Bishop takes e4
assess is definitely hit definitely too
cheeky I was originally I was thinking
about this kind of move but of course I
hadn't really thought about a king
cytotec suddenly coming over me now yeah
he's putting this on the board sir it's
it's it's always very dangerous
definitely no so I'm always under you to
take him
yeah black is black is the black is in
trouble that that's clear maybe after
after Knight b6 we can we can just go
here this kind of thing it's just just a
problematic I don't know I don't know
it's very difficult or maybe here I mean
I wanted to briefly check after I took
on c4 how bad is this really what is the
computer computer are interesting the
computer gives this defense which I
didn't think of at all this actually
makes lots of sense that that's very
interesting if he takes now I have night
of 8 and all of a sudden I'm golden so
nothing terrible there this is
surprisingly surprisingly resilient and
I'm not mated I have exchanged lots of
pieces so this is maybe the way to
defend the whole thing this is what the
computer is giving now quite obviously
has a strong compensation but ok what I
did is should probably lose ya minus two
so I should lose went here d 5 is also
right this is the only move takes takes
takes yeah look hmm I didn't know I went
to hook c8b 5 Queen B 6 and yeah this
this keeps an edge it keeps an edge look
see one not so okay take stakes and now
Luke see form and this is just I mean
why it is just clearly better he has not
sacrificed any material he just has this
position for free and he's got the
advanced beep on the two bishops and yam
they're up
ideas like that coming when my queen is
expelled so he was basically a in a
winning position until he allowed this
rook takes his six Jack it's just a
matter of white can struggle on but it's
definitely losing okay well lucky win
thanks for watching